so last night people noticed
i think it was the athletic first notice
that the mavericks were not playing the
national anthem
during their home games this year 13
games they had not played the national
anthem pregame
and apparently that was cool with the
league cuban mark cuban
had consulted with commissioner adam
silver and because
of the unusual nature of this year
no no fans at games they had relaxed
some of their requirements from from
a pregame standpoint um
and while the nba rule book required
players a standard in the national
anthem adam silver
he hadn't really enforced it as you know
michael since healing became
somewhat popular uh in recent years
in terms of protests and social
injustice during the anthem so before we
could even bring this story to today's
show
because i was going to tell you michael
we'll see how long this lasts
the nba is not in
so the nba because my take was gonna be
oh wait this is okay now that people
noticed
let's see how long they can continue to
do this
the nba released a statement this
afternoon
uh saying this is from chief
communications officer mike bass
he said with nba teams now in the
process of welcoming fans back into
their arenas
all teams will play the national anthem
in keeping
with long-standing league policy
now uh sham sharanya from the athletic
had already said that
mark cuban his decision had nothing to
do with not loving the us but because
many peop many in his organization feel
that the anthem doesn't represent them
and they want to continue the discussion
of how to represent people from all
communities when honoring the us at a
game
so then mark cuban responds to today's
development by saying we respect and
always have respected the passion people
have
for the anthem in our country but we
also loudly hear the voices of those who
feel the answer does not represent them
we feel that their voices need to be
respected and heard because they have
not been
amen going forward our hope is that
people will take the same passion keep
that same energy
as my words not here that they have for
the same intensity
and apply the same amount of energy
there it is sorry keep apply the same
amount of energy
to listen to those who feel differently
from them only then
we can move forward and have courageous
conversations
that move this country forward and find
what unites us
they kept it all by saying listen learn
unite
um and so
i see you processing it michael again i
had every attention my
take was going to be same as colin
kaepernick
he was sitting for the national anthem
until the aforementioned steve
weiss asked him why
he explained it the rest is literally
history
right and i saw this last night i was
like this is good
this is the right thing to do bravo to
the mavericks but i'm telling you i was
going to i was going to say
we'll see how long this lasts now that
people are paying attention to it
sure enough they're slowly but surely
letting fans back in the games
and adam silver and and the nba you know
what they're doing they're getting out
ahead of it
because they knew where this was gonna
go and and the nba
as progressive as we like to think that
the nba is
and and they've earned that reputation
to some extent
now they have this corporate and they
haven't to some extent
relatively relatively speaking
relatively speaking
when you compare to the nfl and major
league baseball sure if somebody got to
have the progressive crown
it's that league if you've got to give
it to somebody it's the nba they're more
and they're more of a players league
and that for that matter a black players
league but
time and time again michael and i agree
with you and this is that this is that
instance
they prove to us what they're really
about or more specifically what they're
not about
which is that life yeah you know what
look
i said over the summer i don't want to
get distracted because i'll come back to
this another time
but i said over the summer let's stop
calling the nba of black league let's
stop it
just because you play my favorite song
just because you got some former players
on the bench as assistant coaches
how many black coaches you got yeah we
keep talking about the nfl
they got a rooney rule uh do you do you
need a rule do you need
our back rule the first uh uh owner the
first uh
uh general manager in professional
sports in all the professional sports
maybe we should call it a culture we
should call it a culturally come on man
it's culturally
come on they got that's what this is
right how many owners how many owners
how many black owners
um how about the commissioner's office
who are your assistants
who are you relying on for your
information but so i'll get back to the
nba on that level for a second
but i always i've always wondered this
even
back in the days when i was covering the
league and
uh stood for the answer mark we got mark
tatum by the way i'm sorry a little bit
of a delay i just heard what you said
mark tatum
um is but i guess what i'm not just
trying to name the one
that's what that means deputy
commissioner i'm not just trying to name
yeah i'm not trying to name the one but
i got you just one i want to see
i want to see i want to see the whole
staff accurate i'd like to see the
office your points
get me on a zoom call and let's go
around the room
right okay let's look at your org chart
let's look at your all right let me see
got you let me see i don't i don't want
to stop straight i don't wanna get you
on track
i'm not gonna get off track but back in
the days when i was covering the league
and standing for the anthem
because that was the thing that was the
thing everybody like no one no one
really sat
for it uh i was covering the nba when uh
mahmoud abdul rauf remember that name
uh he decided that he wasn't going to be
out there
for the anthem because it did not
represent him
and he got a lot of pushback and then he
was out there
i think he was with the nuggets at the
time
so when i was covering a leak i always
wondered
why do we need this why do we need this
so much in sports
because let's say mike you're not a
sports fan there are lots of
there are more non-sports fans in the
country than there are sports fans
believe it or not
so if you're not a sports fan when do
you
hear the anthem when do you hear it
you don't you don't and it doesn't and
no
the olympic inauguration yeah yeah yo
you don't
and uh and so those people they don't
play it at work every day
those people who are not allegiance
that's about it right
those people who are not season ticket
holders uh to nba teams
at different times so that's 41 home
dates and let's say you go to 25 of them
so those people who don't who don't uh
stand with their hand over their heart
and gentlemen please remove your hats
they sit out all the time in charlotte
but those people who are doing that for
the anthem
those those 25 times if you don't hear
it those 25 times
a year are you less american are you
less patriotic
do you not think about the values of
this country so the people who go to
sporting events
and stand there and look around to see
who
else who who's not paying attention or
who's kneeling
or who's doing something else yeah so
you can kind of shame them
right are those the real patriots and
everybody else is just like
they're just taking it for granted that
they're american citizenship ever since
this started with colin kaepernick it's
so ridiculous i've been saying
why i've been saying why do people
think that patriotism has anything to do
with posture
the people doing the kneeling were more
patriotic
in the truest definition than the people
who were condemning and vilifying those
who were peacefully protesting
uh in the name of uh now we know that we
know that for sure now don't we after
january
26 brutality we know that right those
were so-called patriots
and and while so from a practical
standpoint michael and we saw in the nfl
people just deciding not to even come
out for the national anthem
instead of trying to like decide who was
going to sit who was going to stand
we're going to do it as a team we're not
going to visit the team blah blah blah
it's like let's just not come out at all
this is an efficient way
to avoid the problem by saying we're
just not going to play it
we're just not going to we forget it
we're just not gonna play it at all
but i don't think that's what mark cuban
was doing here i actually give mark
cuban credit and i've been critical of
mark cuban quite a bit over the years
but he seems to have uh taken the
opportunity to educate and enlighten
himself
during this movement i appreciate what
he's saying
because like
this anthem and this didn't start with
colin kaepernick this goes back to
jackie robinson
what this anthem does not mean
the same thing to you as it does to me
as it does to michael holly as it it
just means something different
setting aside with the actual words the
context
and the background of the the the lyrics
to the national anthem are let's set
that aside for a second
right all right i'm talking about
strictly
feeling pride and patriotism
it is hard for all of us to take pride
and feel patriotism and feel
loyalty and love for a country that more
often than not does not love us back and
if you're telling me then
leave it tell that to the people who who
stormed the capital too
okay i love america so much until i
reserve the right to criticize her
perpetually
james baldwin okay so michael and
here's another bit of hypocrisy before i
pass it back to you
the hypocrisy is stick to sports
i don't like my politics mixing with
sports
i like my food touching ain't nothing
more political
nothing more nationalistic than playing
the national anthem before a sporting
event it is inherently political
it is inherently political so those same
people that say stick to sports
want to have a want to feel some kind of
way about the national anthem
being played or in this case not being
played before games and the nba is
capitulating
proactively in advance to the people who
they know are going to get pissed off
not at it's been drawn some attention
has been drawn to it but let me ask you
something michael what does it say that
nobody noticed after 13 games it wasn't
a story what did it say to nobody
unbelievable
unbelievable right uh and and
so this is the nba the nba has been
doing i don't know when the nba started
uh with the anthem before games as long
as i can remember so i started covering
the league
uh in 1992.
yeah the 92-93 season was my first year
covering the nba
so as long as i can remember it was
there but what
what people don't recall is that the nfl
never did it
for a long time the nfl didn't do it it
wasn't a big deal
until there was a partnership a business
relationship
uh between the nfl uh and
and the services and the armed services
military yep
yeah so no and i was going to say the
army but it's not it's more in the army
it was like
it's a business it was a business
relationship
and so as part of that relationship we
started to have it and i think that was
in the late 90s
so there were many times where nobody
was really paying attention
as a matter of fact even when the nba
had it uh there's a former celtic you
know him and i know him uh
too know him very well cedric maxwell
when he played he played in the 70s and
80s
he didn't go out for the anthem and
everybody knew it
he didn't go out he'd say hey i was you
know i'm using the bathroom or doing
something else or i have just
you know something with my equipment but
he would always be
in the locker room for the anthem then
he would come out and it was no big deal
now it has become a thing
uh for people to notice but i always but
i still come back to like the love of
country
what is it what what signifies your love
for the united states of america what is
it
is it is personal patriotism is personal
man what is it
right if like if you don't have the if
you don't have the anthem
do you ever do do you is there some is
there something that you do
is it something that triggers you to uh
think about your gratitude
for the country your love for the
country your respect for the admiration
any kind of reflection
i i i just have a hard time believing
that
the only people who do it are sports
people
and if sports people don't do it
everybody else is just
unwashed and simple you putting the flag
outside of your house are you are you
standing up for the national anthem
which
you know at attention that doesn't make
you more of an american or more
patriotic or that doesn't that's not
that's just because that's your love
language that doesn't mean you love
america or what it purports to stand for
more than the next person who doesn't
and i i
i have as much respect as the next
person i have family members i have
friends
who have served and sacrificed in the
military
i mean much respect is the next person
for our service men and women and their
families
i know service men and women and their
families who are frustrated
about how this country treats them
right not just minorities not just
people of color
not just black people veterans
veterans your president your former
president
your former president called them losers
and so what's in it for them what's in
it for them but he was considering it
was a quote but he was patriotic
exactly but he was patriotic words
tweeted this michael
he said that once fans were increasingly
back in arenas including in dallas
there was little chance that adam silver
would let ma the mavs continue without
playing the anthem
roge also said maybe there's a
collective conversation in the nba or
sports to be had on the issue but silver
wasn't letting
one team make that uh decision
i would have loved to have seen how i
played out i would have loved to have
me too but uh the tension
that would have played it reminds me of
roger goodell said our fans want us to
stand
on our players to stand right we're
fighting right
we're fans right who are you talking
about who you are right
which fans right you know what i mean
like okay
i know which fans you're talking about
but you clearly didn't pull me or the
people that i
i have no problem with that i wonder
exercising
their right to not stand for the
national anthem
you know instead of trying to avoid that
i got to give let's embrace it i thought
we had grown up i got to give cuban
i got to give cuban credit on this one
like if
if that story hadn't been written how
long do we go
how long before somebody notices mike
it the nba season started
in december here we are in february
there was no announcement
there was nobody talking about it
there's no no he just decided no we're
not doing it
and you got one of the highest profile
players in the league and luca doncic
i mean you got so many things that you
pay attention to for the dallas
mavericks
and nobody i mean it's really funny if
you think about it
because we get so worked up about these
things
because we've been trained in some cases
to get worked up about these things
i'm going to say that it actually
doesn't really mean you care that much
you don't care that much
no you know no they don't care because
because i mean we do know that it was
never about the anthem and it was never
about the flag
i'm sorry for for the for the cheap
seats for the people in the back
sorry i'm assuming that we've already
established that fact
it wasn't about the anthem it wasn't
about the posture it wasn't about the
knee
it wasn't about the none of that so what
about the flag what about the military
it was about the cause being
protested it was about the fact that
this is about
black people demanding that we stop
getting killed by agents of the state
that piss people off full stop had
nothing to do with the rest of that
stuff
so i'm sorry but i thought we all knew
that michael thank you thank you for
reminding me because everybody may have
got to come to that
realization you know sometimes you got
to remind people like where this really
is
what time it really is you know what i'm
saying everybody got their watch set
right
um caught out i do appreciate
but i do appreciate though you know
cuban just saying
we're not doing it because let's put the
statement back up i mean and we'll give
cuban um
you know up coming up on break gary if
we could put
because i thought the statement it
wasn't just your typical
statement it was like look we hear
loudly the voices of the of those
who feel the anthem does not represent
them
their voices need to be respected and
heard
our hope is that people will take the
same passion that they have for this
issue
and keep that same energy apply the same
amount of energy
to listen to those who feel differently
from them bravo
mission accomplished mission
accomplished
as far as far as if this is about
driving the conversation
mission accomplished uh and i think the
nba
instead of uh again they're letting fans
back in
you could put i mean you put black lives
matter on the court last
in the bubble right black lives matter
right
i i i i've been lapsing on league pass
is black lives matter still on the court
i don't think i've seen it this year i
haven't seen it
but black lives still matter though
right just i'm just wondering
i would hope so i may have missed the
memo whether or not there was a shelf
life
on them on the movement for black lives
matter i i hope maybe they got some
letters
maybe they've been reading all these
thing pieces about ratings and whatnot
and politics and you know stick to
sports
i don't know i don't know um we got much
more
damn it's already 420 oh my gosh names
out of names not on jerseys either
you don't you don't have uh you don't
have uh you know the the names on you
know equality
or yeah you know educational reform
you don't have that on jersey yeah hey
thanks for watching brother from another
on youtube
make sure you hit subscribe before you
leave and be sure to watch us
3 to 5 p.m eastern time on peacock
appreciate you